a huge controversy has wracked the cs go
community
the decision by face it admins running
flashpoint season 3
to replay a game that had already been
completed
for some it was an example of a big org
flexing their muscle
to get the outcome they wanted for
others it was a disaster from the get-go
and potentially
mishandled by the face at admins running
flashpoint
but wherever you land on this issue one
thing is clear
the cs go community isn't happy and
they shouldn't be
listen i'm sure a lot of people involved
in this situation regret their tweets
life choices maybe even more but you
know what you won't regret
subscribing to the score esports youtube
channel
hit that subscribe button ring the
notification bell
leave me a comment about how i
apparently look like maggie
gyllenhaal and that way when we have
fresh
content available you'll see it right
away
okay so let's start at the beginning on
friday may 14th
ninjas in pajamas faced anonymous
esports a polish esports organization
as part of flashpoint season 3. in case
you missed the recent news the series
was also the debut of device
the ex-astralis superstar that ninjas
and pajamas added to their already
impressive roster
don't get me wrong mechanically simple
is the de facto filthiest fragger ever
to touch cs go with
zywoo hot on his trail but in terms of
results
accolades and well pretty much every
other metric you can imagine
device takes the cake it's not even
close it's fair to say that a lot of
people
expected nip to win but when the time
came for the match to get underway on
friday
there was a long technical pause due to
a complaint from nip that
they were experiencing severe lag due in
part at least
to packet loss to really oversimplify
this
packet loss happens when some of the
data saved between
a player's go client and a server just
never arrives what this could look like
is your enemy's positions may not update
accurately on your end your position on
the map may be different than it is at
the server's end
or you might experience delays in
equipping or firing weapons
ultimately the results are unpredictable
because well
some of the data got through and some of
it didn't and
if enough of it doesn't get through it's
basically an f in the chat boys scenario
anyways nip called for a technical pause
and tried to see what could be done
about the situation
there was some discussion of changing
servers because they were able to
connect to their german practice server
no problem
and in fact the face it admin tried
changing from the default german server
to some of their other servers but the
same problems were experienced by nips
players on all of those
eventually the admin said look we've
been at this for like an hour
one team isn't having any problems we
have to get the match underway
nip claimed that due to rmr rules they
weren't allowed to have
staff in the room with the players so
they were essentially left alone to deal
with this issue
so with that ruling by the admin the two
teams loaded into the default german
server and they played the match
and on map one nip actually won it
easily
i think it's fair to say there was
minimal resistance here on overpass but
perhaps for an honor mode the game has
just begun we'll find out
when we head to new but the second two
didn't go their way
anonymous were declared the victors and
the whirlwind
began on twitter where device kicked
things off with a tweet that
he later apologized for nip's ceo and
owner also chimed in
saying that this is the last rmr event
the flashpoint should be allowed to host
and this tweet was seemingly deleted
reactions to these tweets in the
aftermath of the laws poured in
but the general sentiment i saw was like
yeah
it sucks that you lost and it sucks that
you had these problems
but one that's not anonymous fault and
they
waited while you attempted to solve
these problems for a pretty long time
two the tournament and mins not
anonymous were the ones who decided that
this best of three had to go ahead under
the current conditions
and three you actually won a map in
dominant fashion
so the stated 30 to 40 percent packet
loss that device tweeted about
seems pretty unbelievable considering
the impact that would have on your
gameplay
and then on saturday nip filed a
complaint about the series to flashpoint
they submitted proof of the connection
problems which
it was later discovered were entirely on
flashpoint's end
due to security settings on the faces
servers that were being used for the
tournament
from a later nip statement problem is
finally found
flashpoint security settings were
partially blocking traffic from nip
to the flashpoint game server therefore
confirming it was not something nip
could control
and or solve flashpoint is ultimately
responsible for the connection issue
so now after the entire best of three
was played
flash pointed men's agree to replay the
match
with a best of one being played on
sunday or a full best of three being
played on tuesday
so that the tournament can continue from
there anonymous
appealed to val for a ruling and
seemingly valve agreed with flashpoint
anonymous initially refused to play
and the organization issued a statement
with their version of events
they said that they offered to
reschedule the match but nib declined
they went one step further and argued
that
faceit was being pressured quote on a
business level
by nip who obviously has a much larger
fan base
and organization than anonymous does
while there's no real proof of pressure
besides the tweets
i will say that having your ceo say that
the tournament organizer shouldn't host
future
rmr events is probably not the right
thing to do
if you want the process to play out
fairly speaking of pressure
an image that seems to show a discord
conversation
with anonymous ceo telling a face and
admin
to keep the rule book in mind during the
technical pause
was also leaked some people seemingly
including nip
in their statement have interpreted this
as pressuring the admin for a
disqualification
but honestly i think that's a stretch
flashpoint responded to the anonymous
statement on sunday
and noted that at the time that these
problems were happening
there had been no official request to
reschedule the match
but come on did no one in the admin team
consider that
one of your teams is literally telling
you that they can't really proceed with
the match under the current conditions
this should have been something that the
admin thought about doing and even if
anonymous didn't submit an official
request
and let's be honest it probably wasn't
their responsibility given that it
wasn't their technical problem
according to the polish organization one
of their players
offered it in chat nip then responded
with a statement of their own on sunday
the one that i read from previously
which revealed the information about the
connection issues
acknowledged that face it admins had
agreed to have the match replayed
and essentially said the ball is an
anonymous court at this point they also
called the anonymous statement
quote shockingly misleading which i
assume is a reference to the fact that
they said that they were being pressured
to replay the series
when in fact that decision had already
been made by the tournament admins
so it was a ruling and as soon as the
rematch had been confirmed
the community noted that there were
actually a lot of games
that they'd love to be able to replay if
given the chance
the takes were pretty funny but you can
also sense the frustration with the
situation in some cases
and yeah that's right i got the boston
major into yet another video
deal with it okay but memes aside where
does this leave us
early tuesday anonymo issued a statement
that they would comply with the request
for a rematch
if only begrudgingly they then replayed
the third map mirage on tuesday
and although anonymous lost it was a
close
16-14 match that showed that that
previous result
wasn't just a fluke the csppa also
issued a statement before the match that
they had been involved in the situation
and that the association's players
disagreed with the final decision in
this case
and in terms of blame i can't help but
think that
it's really the admins that [ __ ] this
one up if you aren't willing to let the
results of that best of three stand
it should never have been played it
should have been rescheduled with enough
time for these technical problems
to be investigated and solved especially
given
that nip only had problems connecting to
face it servers
this is an opinion that sponge also
echoed on the hl tv confirmed podcast
the point is if the server conditions
were not good enough the game should
have been called off and rescheduled for
an rmr event right like
if this was like a broadcast and it was
like you needed to hit the timings or
whatever
like i'm not saying it should ever it
should never happen and i don't want
this to open up as an excuse right for
players just to be able to not play
because they
they like malek said they have one 1.25
king packet losses like ridiculous
but if you have the players load into
that server and start playing the game
then everybody involved has to agree
that yeah
this is the actual game and we agree to
be bound by the results of that game
anonymo may have lost to nip in the
rematch but i'm willing to bet that they
won
something else too fans that want to see
them succeed
because of the way they were treated
this team could be a lot of fun to
follow
and there's nothing like a david and
goliath narrative to get people's
emotions running
hot if these two teams ever meet again
at the end of the day the problems here
were caused by the decision that face it
admins came to initially
as well as the server setup which caused
the connection problems that nipple have
it
flashpoint commissioner monte cristo
admitted as much
after the rematch and it really sucks
that anonymous
ultimately was punished for that but
whether you think the rematch was fair
play
or you've changed your profile picture
to this
one thing seems pretty universal i can't
wait to have lance back
i'm trying to power it up bro okay so
let's start at the beginning
again let's start at the beginning
constantly like we can't stop starting
at the beginning okay so let's start at
the beginning on
okay so let's start at the beginning on
friday may 14th
ninjas and pajamas was set to face off
again
i don't know i said i don't know i said
that
goddamn colton's gonna destroy me hi
guys i haven't
i haven't recorded a video in like four
weeks okay
listen they got me doing some crazy [ __ ]
they don't have me getting in front of
cameras
they have me doing other crazy [ __ ] that
i can't talk about okay
so just trust me on this i'm not doing
this on purpose okay here we go